[Music]
becky is with us in prescott arizona hi
becky welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi ken good to talk to you too
you too i'm mom
i'm
kind of needing your help i have a
daughter who's uh married and has a
little two-year-old and they both are
teachers she's a stay-at-home online
teacher he teaches for a small public
school
they would like to buy a home and they
really don't have the income to do it
and i would like to help
but i'd like your
advice of what are some possibilities
for helping them get a home
i know you said don't outright buy it
and then have them rent be tenants
because that makes thanksgiving dinner
very strange
but what what ideas do you have for
helping our kids get into a home
if they don't have the funds to to get
that started
okay
well
the first thing is is that if you help
someone
get into a situation that harms them
that by definition is not helping them
and i think that is the core of what
you're asking as to how to do this
wisely so that they're not harmed but
when you say they can't afford it three
times in your question
um that scares me a little um
that they just don't make enough to pay
the payments we're about to sign them up
for we don't want to do that right
right and i know you say 25 of your
take-home should be what is
going towards that house yeah
so maybe the way you help them is you
coach them a little on their careers
maybe the way you help them is we coach
them on their budgeting and get them out
of debt they need to be out of debt and
have an emergency fund before they talk
about buying a house but if they're
managing money really well on their
modest income
and they're out of debt and they have
their emergency fund and they just don't
have enough down payment and you want to
give them a hundred thousand dollars of
your 5 million for them to be able to
buy a house as a bigger down payment as
a gift i don't have any issue with that
at all i don't want you to give someone
anyone money who's misbehaving with it
because you are not blessing them
no they're doing actually well i put
them through fpu they have been on a
budget uh they are not in debt they have
their emergency fund
but that leap especially with real
estate uh
and tell me this do you think this is
the time to buy it and one should wait
on buying a home what's your opinion on
the timing right now well the market's
really hot obviously it's white hot and
um
the uh uh
it's not the it's not a buyer's market
it's a seller's market
so but does that mean you can't buy
right now no but i mean you just have to
be wise don't get in a you've seen these
movie scenes like with an old jerry
lewis movie where somebody gets super
excited at an auction and loses their
mind and bids like seven times what
something's worth that's what some
people are doing with houses right now
and so you don't want to do that you
don't want to lose your mind
and uh there are people that have lost
their minds in this market and so if you
can be calm and wise and walk away from
enough deals to find one that is a
reasonable purchase in their situation
then again it's not you can't say no
don't buy in this market but it's a
difficult market to
get a a reasonable to good buy-in
because it is a seller's market without
a doubt so here's the thing
um
i had a friend who
gave his children
the money to pay cash for their first
home
after they were behaving with money
wisely
and we're saving
and they were getting ready to just go
get a normal mortgage and he just
gave them money he's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars he had the money won
the big deal
and uh so they bought like an 800 000
house or whatever and he just bought it
and handed it to him no strings attached
the only thing he did ask them to do
because he's like you and me becky he
financial peace university person right
and he said um
i just want you to sign a letter
swearing you'll never borrow money again
that's all i want you to do
so that my grandkids never go in debt if
i do if i give a gift that this is this
lavish that we truly have broken the
chain mathematically on this family tree
and uh
and
then he stepped back and was not
controlling and didn't interfere in
their life didn't question their
vacations anything else he just wanted
to keep their word what they said they
would do
and uh that way that's the last person
in his family tree to borrow money
and you know those kids those kids were
millionaires almost instantaneously
as a result because of their their net
worth
yeah i think that's absolutely the right
advice and becky you know
they're a young couple seems like
they're doing all the right things and
and the reality is is help them be
patient and you yourself need to be
patient in this time you know and so
it's look it's going to cool off at some
point even if it doesn't you have the
discipline like dave said to be able to
walk away from those deals and uh i i
think you're a great lady with a great
heart but you know this every young
couple wants to get in a house and the
reality is is that it's never worth
getting in a house but not being able to
do what you need to do to take care of
it to be able to you know fix it up and
i think that's a temptation right now
and sometimes people are making too big
of a
rather too quick of a leap into this and
i'll tell you you have to be real
careful of the
tendency for control in these situations
um
i'll just share with you that becky i
think the hardest stage of parenting is
when your children are grown
because you can no longer tell them what
to do
and you just ha you know not if you want
well you can you can tell them what to
do but it doesn't work right but i mean
you know you just have to
my kids thank god i've not done a bunch
of stupid stuff but i'm i'm of the age
that my friends have grown kids that are
35 or 40 years old or or 25 years old
and the kid is off the ranch and you
know doing stupid stuff and you can't
stupid is not illegal
and it is very difficult to have
good relational boundaries with your
grown children for all of us me included
um i do but my kids have also been
taught well enough about boundaries when
i don't they they step in
and uh remind me uh but but if you're
going to get in a financial transaction
like this where you're giving them some
money
then you really got to fight that urge
to control that urge that does not give
you additional rights to speak into
their life you gotta cut bait
emotionally walk away act like for the
rest of your life you didn't give them a
dime it's good and and here's something
else on that line dave i think that
you're right about this you know a lot
of parents
they are still the most influential
voice in their adult kid's life and this
young couple's in a good place right now
they don't have debt they're on a budget
uh they're they are listening to becky
and that's why which is great but don't
put pressure on them that already exists
from culture which says you got to buy a
house you got to buy a house you know
and and i think sometimes parents
unwittingly uh will steer kids in the
wrong direction just because you feel
that cultural pressure as well they're
in good shape and they've got time
they're a young couple you know prior to
1970
uh for a uh young married couple to buy
a home in their first five years of
marriage
was highly unusual yeah i think that's a
good thing
it was it was highly unusual only in the
last couple generations have we deemed
it mandatory yeah you know you've been
married five minutes what's wrong with
you yeah you know and i'm not saying
becky's doing this no there's a thing
out there that's that that is that thing
yeah it's very real and and so just be
careful with all of it but it sounds
like she's being very wise i didn't hear
anything in there except she's really
worried about them being able to afford
the payments they're all about to sign
up for yeah and you got to be careful
with that one